DAVID GLAZER: All right,
good morning, everyone.
Welcome to first session of day
two of Google I/O. Hope
everyone had a great
day, yesterday.
We're going to spend
most of our time
answering your questions.
There are two microphones in
the aisle, and as there are
people queued up the
microphones, you guys get
precedence over just about
anything that we would want to
say because we're here
to chat with you.
We're sitting down and we don't
have slides because this
is meant to be a conversation.
I want to start off with a
little bit of introductions,
both ways, so I'm going to ask
the folks who are sitting up
here with me to give you a
little bit of information
about who they are, and what
their areas are, and the kinds
of questions they are best
able and best capable to
answer from you all.
I'm going to ask you, as an
audience, a couple of
questions, show of hands kind of
things, just to get a sense
of who's who here.
But at any point, feel free to
step up to the mics and we'll
jump in once we get
through that.
So I'll start.
I'm David Glazer.
I'm the Director of Engineering
for the Google+ platform.
We're the team that's
responsible for connecting
what people do on Google and in
Google+ with what they do
everywhere else, on all
the apps, all the
sites, that they visit.
And we can go deeper into
any part of that as
you want, later on.
I've been at Google for about
seven years, now, so I've
worked on different projects and
different teams at Google,
and this is one of
the fun ones.
So why don't we start
at that end.
Jen, you wanna introduce
yourself.
JENNIFER LIN: Hi, I'm
Jennifer Lin.
I'm an Eng Manager on the
Google+ platform team.
I specifically work on building
Android and iOS
libraries for you guys,
so you could connect
users to Google+ Sign-In.
And I also work on offering
you guys REST APIs.
I've been at Google for six
years, and this is the second
team I've been on.
VIC FRYZEL: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Vic Fryzel.
I lead developer relations for
Google+ and Google Apps.
I've worked at Google for
almost four years now.
My team is generally responsible
for delivering a
good developer experience
from end-to-end.
So when you first decide to
adopt Google+ and integrate,
all the way out of launching
your application in production
and then maintaining
it over time.
So we're responsible for things
like the documentation,
and the samples.
We work with a lot of you in a
one-on-one capacity, in which
your integration requires
some special attention.
But really, we're focused on
making your integration as
simple as possible.
CHEE CHEW: Hi, I'm Chee.
I manage the engineering
team for Hangouts.
So prior to yesterday, people
understood that to be the
video chatting system.
And now we've expanded that to
include the new app that
includes text messaging and
media, all up through video.
SANDY JEN: Hi, I'm Sandy Jen.
I came to Google less than a
year ago through the Meebo
acquisition.
I was one of the founders,
with Seth here.
I am an Eng Manager on
the publisher side.
So all the publisher offerings
to help gain audience and
eyeballs to your apps and sites,
my team takes control.
SETH STERNBERG: Hi
there, I'm Seth.
So, like Sandy said, I also
joined just under a year ago
with Meebo acquisition.
So I'm David's counterpart.
I run product for the
Google+ platform.
I'm-- just one quick second on
the Google+ platform, for
those who missed it yesterday.
Like David said, the goal is
to make it really easy for
users to bring the best of their
Google experience with
them to the rest of
the internet.
So when they're on a given
site-- like a couple days ago
we launched with Forbes--
they can see recommended content
as they're scrolling
through articles in Forbes,
and see really interesting
other articles that they
might want to see.
Or, because we know they have
an Android phone, if they
connect with a website of yours,
and they say hey, I
want to go ahead and sign in
with Google+ Sign-in Then we
say, would you like the Android
app, too, right?
So great for the users
for app discovery.
Great for all of you because
it drives more Android
installs, where you tend to
have more engaged traffic.
So the goal for users is bring
Google with them to the
internet and then best
of their internet
experience back to Google.
Talk about specifics later
on in this session.
At the same time, for you guys,
all the product that
we're putting out should
drive you.
There are more unique users,
more engaged users, right,
which means more page views,
or create a completely
seamless experience between
mobile and desktop.
We should make it so that you
form a relationship with your
user and your service.
Not your user, and your service,
and a device, which
is just too complicated.
So I'm sure we'll get to talk
more about that to you.
DAVID GLAZER: I'm okay
with the mic.
OK.
Yeah.
All right.
So that's us.
Let me get to know you guys
a little bit better.
In no particular order, I'm
trying to get a sense of how
much you have already, or are
interested, in using different
parts or different features
of our platform.
So let me start with how many of
you manage a Google+ page?
That's a large fraction of the
audience, that's interesting.
How many of you have
written nontrivial
code in the last year?
OK.
How about in the last decade?
My hand goes up in the
last decade, but
not in the last year.
OK.
Of the people who've written
code, how many of you have
written web code?
Whether back end, front
end, something that's
backing a web page?
OK.
How about Android code?
iOS code?
OK.
That's a good mix of
all the above.
I happened to ask them in the
order hands got a little bit
smaller for each of those
questions, but a good mix of
all of the above.
How many of you have put a
Google+ widget on a website?
Probably a +1 button because
it's the one that's been up
the longest.
All right.
How many of you have integrated
Google+ sign-in
into something?
All right.
We've got somewhere between
10 and 20 hands
went up for that one.
How many of you--
OK, so now I'm going
to look forward.
How many of you think that over
the next year you will be
integrating Google+ sign-in into
something you're doing?
About three times as many
hands as before.
All right.
That's useful.
Hangouts.
How many of you have been in
a Hangout in the last week?
OK.
How many of you have used
an app in a Hangout?
an app other than a
mustache in a Hangout?
How many of you have built
a Hangout app?
OK, that's about seven
or so, like there.
All right, that's great,
that's useful.
I'm very happy to see that mix
of things because there's a
I'm seeing a fair amount of
interest in all of the
different things that we all can
help answer questions on.
I invite you guys
up to the mic.
I'll ask questions if you don't,
but mine are going to
be softballs, all right.
If you want the hard questions,
you need to ask them.
So come on up.
Oh, great.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When Google+ started,
it was seen by some
as blogging service, by some
as something unknown.
Then it was clear it's
not a blogging
service, something more.
It moved in public cognition
to something more like
Pinterest, or something
like that.
How do you want to see Google+'s
identity in the eyes
of your users, in
the long term?
What's the, if not arrival
point, but the reasonable
milestone in terms
of what it is?
How you define it?
DAVID GLAZER: Yes.
That's a good question.
I'll take a first crack at
it, but anyone else who
wants to jump in--
I think the way to understand
Google+ from Google's point of
view is there happens to be a
product at plus.google.com,
and on the mobile apps.
It's a great product.
It's a very important product,
and it's not the main point.
What Google+ really is is it's
a way for Google to get to
know our users.
It's a way for Google to have
a relationship with people,
where we know something about
who our users are.
We know something about who
they're in relationships with,
who else they care about, and
we give them a way to share
with other users, and with
people that they know, or
people that they might
want to know.
And that layer, that spine,
that backbone, really is
designed to make all
of Google better.
Can Search be better,
if we knew you were?
Could Maps be better,
if we knew we were?
Well, if you saw the keynote
yesterday, you know the answer
to both of those is yes.
Could YouTube be better,
if we know who you are?
Could Docs be better, if
we know who you are?
Could Gmail be better, if we
knew more about the ways you
connect with other people?
We already, obviously,
know who you are.
That's the real point of
Google+, is to allow that
notion of who people
are as people.
To be available across
all of Google.
And then, with this team,
to also be available for
everything else that
you do online.
Within that, all of the
hypotheses you tossed out--
the answer is yes.
Is it useful for a blogging
service to
know who people are?
Of course.
Is it useful for a content
discovering and curation
system to know who people and
who they're connected to?
Yes.
Is it useful for a conversation
system to know
who people are and what
they care about?
Yes.
So all those end up
being important
features of "who are you".
Anyone?
SETH STERNBERG: Let me give you
a couple of examples to
bring some of those
points, because I
think it's pretty important.
So, if you think about Hangouts,
and what we were
talking about with Hangouts and
what Chee and team built,
just very recently.
Hangouts, if you think
about it, are--
it's a social piece
of Google, right,
that's woven into Gmail.
That's woven into
plus.google.com.
You'll see that across
properties, right, to make it
really easy for users to
communicate with each other
live across various
Google properties.
If you think about what's
happened with Google+ sign-in,
and how an application can write
app activities that a
user's taking.
So, for example, TuneIn, writing
to Google, hey, here
are the music stations
that our users are
listening to in TuneIn.
And then we take those, and we
aggregate them anonymously,
and we put them into Search.
So when someone does a search
for TuneIn, they can see what
actual people are doing inside
that app at Search, and have
more context before they
ever go there.
And then when they click on
that radio station that
interests them because they can
see what's hot in TuneIn
right now, they're a very
qualified user that's heading
over to that particular
property, in that case TuneIn.
Or when someone sends an
interactive post, right.
So this is based on, obviously,
we know who you are
inside a given application,
like at OpenTable.
We know you want to send
something to a friend of
yours, and if you write your
friend's name, then that post
goes through all Google
properties, right, because it
hits the notifier, which appears
in Search, and in
YouTube, and it goes on the
stream inside Google+.
So like David said, all of the
features, if you really break
it down, right, they're about
connecting a user seamlessly
across all Google properties
with who they are and who
their friends are.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Just, maybe to follow up.
My question is not how Google
sees the Google+, but how you
want the users to see it.
And, so far, I don't hear
anything specific, so my
takeaway, then, and I just want
to check if it's right,
that Google doesn't want user,
per se, to see Google+--
CHEE CHEW: No.
AUDIENCE: --to see what's
on the top of it.
Is that fair?
DAVID GLAZER: That's
a good question.
CHEE CHEW: I think the way I
think about this is we want
users to see Google+ as a real
reflection of their life.
We designed circles to better
enable you to really reflect
that your connections to
people, to friends, and
family, co-workers, are
at different levels.
Your interactions with them
are at different levels.
We designed Hangouts to bring
you face-to-face, so that
interactions are real.
We want to facilitate very real
interactions that you
have with your friends, your
family, your neighbors, your
acquaintances, other
people around the
world, in a real way.
But bring that to the web, and
to the internet, and bring the
people around the world closer
by using technology.
But still is making it
as real as possible.
I think that's how we want
people to perceive Google+.
Does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So I take it as-- essentially,
it's a embodiment of the
connections which users
have in real life.
CHEE CHEW: And making
that richer.
Facilitating it.
AUDIENCE: --connection to
the information world.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah.
That's exactly right.
And because there's many kinds
of connections, there's many
ways to use.
All right.
Let's go to the back
microphone.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I had a question on Google
Apps for Business.
How do you want Google+
to be viewed for
Google Apps for Business.
So do you think that Google+ is
evolving into some kind of
a Yammer for businesses?
Or is it evolving into just a
contact discovery and intranet
page for businesses?
What's the direction?
What's the vision and mission?
DAVID GLAZER: So Vic, do you
want to take this one?
VIC FRYZEL: So, I'm sorry, was
the question how we're
targeting Google Apps
for Business,
integrated with Google+?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
So Google+ is made available
for Google Apps for
Businesses, right?
How does Google Apps--
how do businesses use
Google+ better?
Is the Google+ platform being
developed in the direction of
being a Yammer?
Or is it being developed in the
direction of being just an
intranet page where people can
share, and it's a social
discovery thing, but not
really a Yammer.
DAVID GLAZER: Maybe we should
talk a little bit about how we
use it internally as one
data point, as well
as what we're seeing.
VIC FRYZEL: So internally,
within Google, we obviously
have our own Google Apps
domain, google.com.
And I would say that we're
maybe the biggest user of
Google Apps.
Yesterday, I received
2000 emails.
And what I would say is that
Google+ coming into Google
Apps for Business in a more
prolific way is actually
having a pretty large impact.
So internally what we do with
Google+ and these social
annotations throughout the
rest of Google are really
fueled by my connections
internally at work.
So I work for a company with
like 50,000 people, and I know
maybe 1,000 of those people.
That's actually--
DAVID GLAZER: And they sent
you email, yesterday.
VIC FRYZEL: They all sent me
an email, unfortunately.
So, when I interact with these
people, there's different ways
in which I need to interact
with them.
So, for instance, I said, when
I started, I work on Google
Apps and on Google+.
So I have circles internally
for the Google+ folks, and
then also for the Google
Apps folks.
And one integration for me
that's really useful is the
integration between circles
and Gmail, for instance.
So now I can much more easily
categorize and find the emails
that are relevant to Google+,
things I'm working on on
Google+, and things I'm working
on on Google Apps.
And that's an example of a
social annotation and a social
integration between our services
that could not exist
without Google+ being there for
Google Apps for Business.
So that's a really, really
compelling feature, and we
have a number of these
other features.
Hangouts, internally, is one of
our most prolific services.
I think we use Hangouts every
day, every meeting I have.
DAVID GLAZER: Chee, do you
know how many hours--
CHEE CHEW: Yeah, we do about
20,000 Hangouts a day,
internally.
So we really work by it.
But also we connect that through
to the rest of Google+
internally, and we share
information out.
And when people have issues or
questions, they don't quite
know who to go to.
Often what they'd do is
they'll use Google+
internally.
And then people will come and
respond to it or Forward it
around and find the
right people.
So I think it's a great tool
to communicate and bring
people closer together, whether
it's outside in your
personal life, or within
a business setting.
DAVID GLAZER: There was a
session, yesterday, it was end
of day yesterday.
The video was not up as of first
thing this morning, but
it will be up shortly, on how to
get the most out of Google+
in your domain and organization
that had some
interesting discussion
about this.
We are just starting to offer
some platform capabilities so
you can program on top of that
and do some making it fit
better in your org.
But, as with the first question,
I think my short
answer to your question
is "all of the above".
Google+ works to add that
layer of "who are my
coworkers" to all of my
interactions at work.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So then, from a business
perspective, there is a
conflict between Google+ for
personal account and Google+
for business account.
How do you really allow
multi-log-in with the Android?
Or is that something
in the development
direction that's happening?
Where you could have a personal
Gmail as well as a
business Gmail coexisting on a
mobile device, wherein you can
switch and toggle
back and forth?
DAVID GLAZER: Everyone who works
at Google lives in that
world of having at least
two accounts.
I bet the average number of the
average Googler has 2.2
accounts, is my guess, with a
few people having multiple
from side things.
And I think my take on
it is living in that
world is not bad today.
Pretty much everything I want
to do with having the two
identities works.
But it's not great
today, either.
And it's getting better.
We keep our cross--
there's Chrome capabilities,
and there are app
capabilities.
The multi-log-in, the Add
Account thing works, browser
profiles is sometimes helpful.
On my phone, I can easily switch
between my two email
accounts, and it's
comfortable.
So I think that category of
people who have two accounts
is going to always be a
minority, and always be a very
large and important minority.
And it's slowly getting
better.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
DAVID GLAZER: All right.
Front mic, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is Mooney Langenic.
I come from a company
called TheAudience
out in Beverly Hills.
And we manage brands.
We manage celebrities' social
media presence.
DAVID GLAZER: Can you
drop a name or two?
Come on, you work at the--
AUDIENCE: You want me to.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah, give
us a name or two.
AUDIENCE: I don't know, I heard
some guy that performed
last night is one
of our clients.
So--
the younger one.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Not necessarily
the better shape
one, the younger one.
We have an interesting model in
this celebrity and agency
type world.
We have to represent
a persona, not
necessarily a person.
So these direct connections
are--
we want people to connect with
a person's image, but not
necessarily--
maybe not them, themselves.
I doubt that Steve Aoki would
want you to know exactly what
he's eating right now.
But he would want to
know what he's
performing, or where he's--
when a new album
is coming out.
So the way that we--
I see that there's all this
hooks in with Sign-On and with
App and everything.
But we have to establish a need
to put these people and
their personas on every social
media platform out there.
And for us, the difficulty
has been--
I see the value in all these
other aspects, but why would I
want to get a celebrity, or a
brand, on Google+ without--
and I think one thing is I would
need to get some type of
value metrics to prove the
benefits of being on Google+
for these brands and these
celebrities because it's hard
to pitch to them.
And so is there anything being
done to address that?
And even though I know it's been
talked about, all this
integration, what about the
feed, what about-- is there a
value in getting these
people on the feed?
Is there going to be any need,
is there going to be any
effort to really get
more people to
interact with the feed?
Or is it just a place to--
you've got to get content on
there so it'll be relevant
for a search.
So that I know how to position
this to our business and to
our clients.
DAVID GLAZER: You want
to take it, Seth?
SETH STERNBERG: So I
think there are a
few answers to that.
It's a really great question.
The first is just focusing on
plus.google.com itself, right.
So the social destination.
I think there are a lot of
ways for celebrities--
for personas, as you say it,
that you can really get a
community engaged and involved
around that person.
One, obviously is if you have
a page for them, right.
Another one is if you choose
to have a profile for them.
We've seen it go both ways,
and in both cases, it's a
great way to have their audience
engage with them, at
least is they're putting
out posts.
One of the advantage is, if they
have a page that's very
active, given that they're a
persona, is that a lot of that
content can make its way
into Google Search.
So if someone went and searched
for the celebrity's
name, right, there's a social
card that will come up on the
right hand side where the ads
usually are, but instead it'll
have recent posts
from the page.
AUDIENCE: And I understand
that.
So what I need to be able to do
is, how can I quantify that
success in a nice report to some
Hollywood executive that
is breathing down my neck.
I can tell them hey, you're
showing up in Search.
Like, no, show me
some numbers.
That's where I am
in terms of--
I need some type of
quantifiable metrics and reporting.
I hear you have this amazing
product called Google
Analytics that would be great
for this, so I'm just
wondering there will be even
plans to integrate with that?
CHEE CHEW: I think that's
good feedback that
we should take back.
I think it's an important point
that you raise, that in
order for you to help your
customers, there's more
information that you need.
I also think that another thing
to think about is that
we're trying to open up new
experiences that you may not
be able to do in any
other platform.
So we have a lot of entertainers
who launch their
albums on Hangouts, Alicia Keys,
and Taylor Swift, and
that sort of thing.
And people can connect with
their fan base in a richer,
new way that they couldn't
have before.
I mean, this morning the Star
Trek crew had a Hangout, which
is kind of a brand new,
innovative experience.
And the feedback that we're
getting is that that
connection is unique, and rich,
and it just takes it to
a new level.
So I think--
DAVID GLAZER: You could maybe
even say to a new frontier.
CHEE CHEW: You might say that.
I would get too many groans
if I say that.
But I think that we should take
your point that like,
you're asking for more
clarity, more
metrics, to help you.
And I think that we also say
there's value in new
experiences that we would--
AUDIENCE: All I'm saying is if
I'm going to tell JJ Abrams
pay me $1 million to have
Hangout, he's going to tell
me, all right, prove to me what
value it gives me, aside
from "it sounds really cool."
CHEE CHEW: It's a fair point.
SETH STERNBERG: And do
know that in the--
so this is something
that we have heard.
The first places that you can
see some metrics coming
through on social engagement
is actually, if you do use
Google+ Sign-In, there's a
dashboard that's available at
your Plus page where you can
see engagement metrics.
How many people are signing
in, how many people are
sending interactive posts--
DAVID GLAZER: It's a start.
SETH STERNBERG: --the
click rate.
It's a start, like David said.
But you will see us continue to
improve there because we do
know it's an area of
desire for people.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID GLAZER: All right, back
microphone, please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Yeah, I have a design
suggestion for you.
So one of the pain points I have
in having a multi-account
sign-in to the Plus site,
plus.google.com.
This typically happens when
I'm landing on a community
page, or a profile page,
of some user.
And I've gotten there because
I've clicked in a link in
Gmail or some other thing and
I'm in the wrong account, that
I want to circle that person in
one of my other accounts,
not that one.
The way you do it now, when you
switch accounts, you just
open up a new page, and I'm in
the home page of my Google+.
I've lost the context
of that person.
And even if I copy and paste the
URL, because of the little
slash u slash n thing, I'm
hopelessly lost about how to
even get back to that page
in the right account.
So I would just suggest that,
when you switch accounts, in
those cases where you're on a
community page or profile
page, you stay there instead of
taking me to my home page.
DAVID GLAZER: That's
a great suggestion.
SETH STERNBERG: I had that
problem this morning.
DAVID GLAZER: How many people
here been burned by that in
the last week?
AUDIENCE: Whoo-hoo!
DAVID GLAZER: All right.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, guys.
DAVID GLAZER: Front
microphone.
AUDIENCE: It's just a
quick question, is--
I've been in process of moving
a bunch of blogs and stuff
into this community because it
has a lot more traction and a
lot more visibility.
The problem is your text
formatting is lacking.
You can't actually bold,
italicize, you can't insert
images into feeds.
You can't do a lot of the basic
stuff that you can do
with Blogger and some
of the other tools.
So if that's one of the
purposes, to generate more
social interaction, more of a
conversation with people, it'd
be great if we actually had the
basic font manipulation
tools that most of your other
products seem to have.
Or I could've missed it, it's
just I've been trying to get
onto the internet in
this room, and it's
a little bit hard.
DAVID GLAZER: There are some
very basic markdown that you
probably do know about,
where you can bold
and italicize text.
And that far from addresses
everything about your question
but it is something.
I've heard that before.
There's a balance that we
are looking for where
we don't want to--
first of all, we don't want to
make it too hard, and second
of all, we don't want
to make it too noisy
for people who are--
like the birth of desktop
publishing, where everyone
showed off they knew
how to pick fonts.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID GLAZER: But I also agree
with you there's a kind of
communication.
So it's a good point.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID GLAZER: Back mic.
AUDIENCE: All right.
First, I want to
make a comment.
Google+, as a platform
for us--
I come from a large
enterprise--
has been phenomenal.
It has absolutely changed
the way we can do work.
The real time collaboration,
we've never seen it before.
We had played around with
looking at what Microsoft has
in the past, and I have to
tell you that that really
never came to fruition for us.
It really didn't meet
what we needed.
But Google+ is one of those sets
of tools where we did the
Google Apps, and then
along comes Google+.
It's a small little thing you
think of, for Hangouts, but
what a great, great tool for
us to collaborate, and have
people bring themselves together
for things that they
need to do.
Adding in things like
collaborating on documents, or
files, or doing screen sharing
or things like that.
It's absolutely just
turned around the
way we can do business.
And so I just want to
congratulate you guys for a
really great tool set.
DAVID GLAZER: Thank you, Chee.
CHEE CHEW: I did not pay him.
[LAUGHTER]
CHEE CHEW: I swear, I have
never met him before.
AUDIENCE: But now I
want to ask you a
separate question, though.
So I think it's for--
I don't really remember
the name, you talked
about iOS and Android.
So, in looking at the tools
you have right now, you've
got-- it's kind of a mishmash,
right now.
You've got this great Google+
apps that's got built in
applications today.
And then you just released
Hangouts, that has Hangouts
and messaging, but you've got
Hangouts and messaging within
the Google+ app.
So is there a plan deprecate
Google+ features and functions
and build out separate
applications for those?
Or what's the long term strategy
and vision on that?
To try to help our--
explain this to our users
properly, so they know--
we can tell them to just do it
one way and not have to do it
multiple different ways.
CHEE CHEW: So let me see
if I got a question.
And correct me before I answer
the wrong question.
So the question is
really around--
since we brought Hangouts top
level, is this a strategy
where we will bring lots
and lots of features as
independent apps?
Is that your question?
AUDIENCE: At the same time, will
you then be deprecating
out of the Google+ apps.
CHEE CHEW: Ah, OK.
So we won't be bringing all
independent functionality and
breaking apart the Google+
app into a whole bunch of
different apps.
But we believed that, for this
particular case, it was
important because this is a use
pattern that people have
with the many other tools
that we provided.
Like Google+ Messenger, and
Talk, and Google Voice.
And, since they're used to
going at it, and getting
access to it, in this way, there
it's top-level, we want
to do a better job of having a
comprehensive tool that still
matches that use pattern.
So I don't think you should look
at this as a strategy for
all Google+ features,
but I think this is
a very unique case.
So I think that's half
your question.
The other half is will we be
removing and deprecating that
functionality out of
the Google+ app?
Yes.
So we will be investing and
continue to invest heavily in
the Hangouts app in the
functionality there, and we'll
reconcile that with
the Google+ app in
the very near future.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you so much.
CHEE CHEW: Sure.
DAVID GLAZER: OK.
Front.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
And the question is about Google
Events, which is a
great feature and very useful.
We are part of the GDG Dublin
Organizer Group, so we're
using that to add events, and
have all the photos and
they're coming from the
people that came.
But there's one feature really
missing is all events are
public events, so open
to everyone.
But we have a limit.
So the room we have, like
80, 100 people.
And there's no way to say, well,
we have a limit of 80,
and then system of
waiting list.
So that would be a great
feature to have.
And then, the other question,
again, about events.
Once and event is finished--
I guess it's a future.
Something that maybe you could
bring in the future is have
some sort of statistics,
or data, about events.
Like how many people came?
And how many people say
they would came, but
never checked in?
Not pair people coming,
but a more general
statistics on the event.
DAVID GLAZER: Those are
two great requests.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I have nothing to announce right
now about any immediate
plans, but those
are good ideas.
AUDIENCE: All right.
DAVID GLAZER: Anyone else?
All right.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
A quick comment, first.
I meet with a couple different
folks in Hangouts each week in
some different industries.
And I just wanted to mention
that we had one last week,
people all over the country,
about five or six
participants.
One of the ladies that was
pretty necessary for the
meeting was not joining, so I
called and said, hey, you
joining us soon.
I'm stuck in traffic, it'll
be about 15 minutes.
Instead of wasting everybody's
time or trying to reschedule,
I remember hearing that
you guys integrated
some phone with it.
We called her.
It worked flawlessly.
She could hear everybody.
We could hear her real well.
It was great.
DAVID GLAZER: Chee, how
much of a marketing
budget did you have?
[LAUGHTER]
CHEE CHEW: $120.
AUDIENCE: When I go I travel
around and I check out Plus, I
like to look at what's Hot, and
then occasionally I look
at Nearby, just to get
a flavor for what's
happening in the city.
And about two weeks ago, I was
in Charlotte, and I went to
what's Nearby, or whatever you
title it, and literally spent
two or three minutes scrolling
through and saw the same guy's
either Spotify songs
or something that
he's listening to.
Just hundreds and hundreds.
Like, every three minutes,
here's what he's listening to,
and it basically drowned
everybody else out.
And my question is, is
that a user error?
Is that a developer error?
Did he flip a bunch of switches
to just say make
everything I do public?
Is that how it comes standard?
And just saying it really
flooded everybody else out.
DAVID GLAZER: First of all, it's
always our problem if you
had a bad experience.
So there may be other things,
but it's always our problem.
SETH STERNBERG: So actually
I'm not quite
sure how that happened.
That was probably the user just
literally choosing the
post everything manually
into the stream.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SETH STERNBERG: Because there is
not a way for developers to
be able to write programmatic
activity like that and have it
all get into the stream.
But a design point--
when we did App Activities, so
when we let developers start
writing activities into
Google's, we really want to
take that and put it into places
that have real meaning
and context for users.
So if you've got to that
person's profile, and you were
specifically looking for what
they had done in a given app,
then you would see the full
stream of what they've
done in that app.
But we are specifically not
just publishing it in the
stream because at this point in
time, like right-- a stream
is chronological, right,
more or less.
And you might not really care
right now that I read an
article or listened to a song.
But if you start searching for
music, great music, later, you
might really care, right.
Or looking for travel
destinations.
You might really care what I've
read about great travel
destinations.
So that-- like David said,
that's probably our fault that
it was able to happen.
But it's definitely
a design point.
What we heard from users was--
it was actually interesting,
they said I want to absolutely
know that I'm not going to
spam my friends.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SETH STERNBERG: But, when I want
to share my friends, I
want to know they're
going to get it.
And that was hard for us to
reconcile, initially, right.
We did a lot of thinking
about that.
And that's why we landed on
programmatic app activities
right into Google do not
just publish to Stream.
But, if a user chooses to share
something, and they
write in a friend's name, then
we're going to pop a
notification to that user in
every Google property, right,
to make certain that
that user's
friends do get that message.
So yeah.
Our fault, but not
a design point.
AUDIENCE: All right, cool.
Thanks.
DAVID GLAZER: In
front, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Diana.
I'm a User Experience Designer
with Bridgepoint Education,
and I wanted to say it's really
exciting what you guys
are doing with the social
platform and changing the
landscape of learning.
And I wanted to ask from
your experience--
or if you could give insight
from an institution level,
from a student level, and from
a professor level, where have
you seen the biggest pain points
being alleviated by
utilizing Google+, or where have
you seen the most value
being added in the learning
or teaching experience?
CHEE CHEW: So I don't
know if you--
did you get a chance to
attend the Coursera--
AUDIENCE: I did.
I did.
Unfortunately, it was a really
short course, and they didn't
get to dive too much into it.
So I was hoping to see if you
guys can add anything to that.
CHEE CHEW: Yeah, so the
observation that we had when
we looked at--
if you guys aren't familiar,
Coursera is online learning.
So it's a MOOC.
And one of the things that we've
noticed is that there's
a large fall off on people who
start the course versus then--
who complete the course.
And we know through
education and--
you just think about
your experiences,
maybe college, or whatever.
A huge part of your memories
and what keeps you going is
actually the interactions that
you have with others, whether
it be other students, or direct
connections you have
with the TAs.
And we also find this
is true with MOOCs.
When people connect with other
people, then they stay with
the program longer.
When they're alone, and studying
alone, and sometimes
getting frustrated alone,
then they fall off.
So what we found through the
work that we've done with
partners is that, when we're
actually able to bring people
face-to-face, that's
been a huge help.
Now, as we've learned, there are
a bunch of challenges in
bringing people face-to-face
around the world, in this
online sort of world.
Some of that is timing,
coordination, and time zones,
and that sort of
stuff, and find
compatibility and language.
And those are the sort of
things that we're really
trying to work through.
But I think there's a lot
of opportunity there.
AUDIENCE: And then from
an institution level?
I mean, I don't know if you've
worked with any brick and
mortar schools, but if you can
share any experiences where on
a university actual
location level.
CHEE CHEW: Yeah.
So we've worked with several
universities on this.
Actually, we found out there are
a lot of universities who
are just trying things and we're
finding out about them
afterwards, which is amazing.
The MIT Media Lab, for example,
has been doing a
bunch of online courses
using Hangouts.
And I think part of the
challenge there is that they
want to reach a very large
audience, hundreds, if not
thousands, of people.
So they're using on-air
and broadcasting.
And two of the most common
requests we get there are for
some universities who want to
restrict that to just a
limited audience.
MIT is a bit more willing to
have the world see it.
But the other one is when you
have a large audience, how do
you manage Q&A with
1,000 people?
I think that's one of the
challenges that we're thinking
through, but also that we find
the partners are able to come
up with other solutions as
well to complement ours.
SETH STERNBERG: So it turns out
my mother's a teacher, and
I was talking to her a little
bit about how she could use--
she asked me.
She was like, hey, you work at
Google+, how can I use this
with my students.
One thing we also talked about
was the idea of creating
community for her class.
And you can create closed
communities.
And so that's a really good
way to just let you as a
teacher and all the students
in your class interact with
each other.
So that's something
you might look at.
The other thing I was pointing
my mother to is, hey, you can
actually create a circle for
everybody in your class, and
that's a really easy way to
share things that you find
that are really interesting
for all of your students.
So there's another couple
things that--
in real life, when my mother
said hey, you know what do I
do, I pointed out to her.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
SETH STERNBERG: Thank you.
DAVID GLAZER: And back.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
How are you?
Couple of issues.
I'm a start up addict.
so currently I have five active
Google Apps accounts in
different domains, plus my
personal Gmail account.
And one of the issues that
I have is that--
well, I have to create a Google+
profile for each
account to administer the pages
for each company and
stuff like that.
But the issue that I have is
that I get people following me
in Google+ accounts where
I don't post.
So the issues that I have
Google+ is that, I can't
consolidate my profiles, or
automatically redirect, or
when they follow me on one
company, say, hey, this is not
an active Google+, please follow
me on my Gmail account,
which is something that I--
actually, I post that, right.
So one of the issues that I have
there is that having so
many Google+ accounts sort of
messes up my online profile.
So when you Google me, you might
get one of the profiles
that I don't actually use.
And It's hard for people to--
investors, actually, as well--
to actually get a hold of me
because they try to reach me
through one of the accounts
that is not really active.
So that's one of the quirks that
I have about Plus, the
profiles themselves.
Also, I'm sort of geek, so I
don't really use Google+ web
profile because I'm
not that social.
But what I do use is the APIs,
and I want to say thank you
for the APIs that were released
about 11 weeks ago.
And I noticed that there are
two subsets of APIs.
There's an HTTP API, which is
mostly REST, to get people
list, circle list, et cetera.
And you have the web API to be
able to do posts, interactive
posts, et cetera.
The issue there is that--
well, to be honest, when I saw
what the web APIs, I figured
hey, this is web, it has to be
REST, I should be able to
actually hack this easily and
make my own REST calls.
I almost got it, but
it never worked.
But that's the thing.
I mean, for the web APIs, why
aren't there HTTP equivalents?
Why am I forced to use the
iframe, or the Google
interface, to share posts?
Why can't it with
server side--
to be honest, I have an
extension, a Chrome extension,
which currently allows a person
to cross post into
Twitter and Facebook.
And I'd love to add,
hey, cross post
this to all your networks.
But I can't.
They have to cross post to
Facebook, Twitter, and then
they take additional step
to post to Google+.
DAVID GLAZER: Let me pick
apart those questions.
On your first question, which
is, hey, you're not social,
but you have a lot
of profiles.
Something like that.
I don't have a magic answer to
that, but there's something
that I've certainly seen other
people use, which is use the
profile picture to encourage,
or discourage, people paying
attention to you.
If you have a picture on one of
them, and not the others,
That's a pretty strong signal
that this is the real you,
this is the one you
care about.
And there are other simple
things, if anyone has other
tips, but that would work.
On your other question--
let me make sure I heard it
right, before answering.
So we have a set of APIs, which
are RESTful APIs, which
are designed for programmatic
access, whatever.
You like that set of APIs,
you like that model of
interaction.
We have another set of
interfaces which are widgets,
which are user present
interactions with the user
that let the user
do some things.
And you're asking how come we
don't let you programmatically
automate all of the capabilities
that we offered
via widgets?
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
Yeah.
DAVID GLAZER: And the answer
to that is very similar to
Seth's answer before.
It's so that you don't cause
problems for our friend who
visits Charlotte by
automatically
writing to his stream.
The intent is we are trying
to say there's a set of
interactions that we really want
to be human-based, human
present, a user actually
did this, interactions.
And the safe way for us to do
that is to say the only way to
do that interaction is
through a Google UI.
So we know for a fact that,
when someone posts, it's
because they saw UI, they saw
it was the Google UI, they
looked at their circles,
they said Share.
And there are legitimate use
cases where programmatic
access would make sense, and
it was the user's explicit
intent, but they're very hard
to tell apart from the
unsavory use cases.
And I trust you, but I don't
necessarily trust everyone
else who might accidentally or
intentionally misuse the kind
of API that would do dangerous
things automatically.
AUDIENCE: But at the same time,
sorry for saying this,
but Google+ has to play catch
up with the other social
networks like Twitter and
Facebook, all right.
So if you have a tool which
allows you to consolidate your
social network access, but you
can't consolidate the access
to Google+.
It's harder to incentivize the
user to-- hey, you also have
Google+, try to see what
advantages it has over
Facebook and Twitter,
for example.
With the tool that I'm
developing, at least, you
can't really do that
because there's an
extra step for Google+.
So you have this tool which
tries to consolidate
everything, but there's always
the exception for Google+, you
have to bring up the widget.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah.
There's a quality-quantity
conversation trade-off, and we
are starting by being very
careful to keep the quality of
the conversation in
Google+ high.
And it is a trade off.
I agree with you, there are use
cases, there is this some
value to a different point.
But we're starting by making
sure that we keep the quality
of the community and the
conversations as human as possible.
And we are willing to take
some short term slower
quantity of information, of
conversation, to have it be
higher quality.
SANDY JEN: The other thing to
think about is that we're not
trying to mimic the interactions
that you'd have
other social networks.
We're trying to create a much
more engaging, human--
like Chee said, real life
equivalent on the web.
And so, in some cases, as David
said before, we don't
necessarily want you to have the
exact same sort of blast
out sequence of events
that you have on
a Facebook or Twitter.
So it could be right now, our
experiences may seem very
similar, but as we developed and
made more product plans,
we hope to differentiate in that
way, so that it becomes
more clear when you'd want to
use Google+, versus when you'd
want to use Facebook,
versus when you
want to use all three.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Thank you very much.
DAVID GLAZER: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm told too tall
for I/O. Am I okay here?
SETH STERNBERG: I wish
I had that problem
of being too tall.
AUDIENCE: Uh, I have
slouch like a geek.
Love Google+, my only complaint
is the multiple
account thing, in terms of
having my Apps account versus
my Gmail account.
It means that I get a lesser
experience throughout Google
as a result.
[INAUDIBLE]
now isn't as good because
Plus is here.
But that's not I want to
be up here, I just
wanted to cut that in.
Quick question.
I work a lot of media
companies-- not like JJ Abrams
who can pay a million dollars,
but poor, dying newspapers.
And I'm trying to convince them
how wonderful Google+ is,
and how they should work with
local business for Google+.
So quick question-- what would
your ideal media organization,
especially a local one,
do on Google+.
And what, in turn, would they
ideally help small local
businesses do on Google+.
SETH STERNBERG: That's a
really good question.
So in terms of a media
organization--
presumably right now a lot of
their traffic, probably their
dominant traffic, is going
to their website.
There are great social
interactions that people
actually are having on that
property that can probably be
used to filter kind of social
data into Google.
So something like, hey, I just
read this article, you might
want to read too.
And if the user does Google+
Sign-In for that property, and
the user sends their friend an
interactive post, that will
have a Read button
on it, right.
So when it goes into the stream,
it will literally have
a big Click Me to send my friend
back to that media
organization.
Same thing for something like
watching a video, right.
Ask your friend to
watch with you.
And send an interactive post
that has a watch button on it.
Or commenting.
I want to hear what you
think about this.
So send an interactive post
with an action to comment.
So one thing we'd love to see
publishers do, both mobile and
web, of course, is send
interactive posts that are
about engagement.
About getting their current fans
to engage their friends
back at that property.
Couple other things.
Creating a Plus page is an
awesome way for that property
to get more traffic and more
engagement inside Google's
ecosystem as a whole.
When we see a people do an
awesome job on Plus pages, and
National Geographic has
done an amazing
job their Plus page.
Wall Street Journal has
done an amazing job
with their Plus page.
They have millions
of followers.
And they have really high
community engagement.
So they've opened up a channel
with their fans inside Google.
And that gets them, obviously,
the social card
inside Google Search.
And so it's even more
discoverability.
So that's another one.
Then the more we talk to
publishers, they obviously are
seeing their traffic shift very
dramatically over to mobile.
So one thing that we've done to
hopefully help is, when a
user does Google+ Sign-In, and
if they have an Android phone,
then we ask, would you like the
Android app of this publisher?
So if a publisher lets a user
say, hey, friend I want you to
watch this video.
When the user takes that action
for the first time, it
will say, in order to send this,
connect your presence
here with Google.
When the user's making that
connection, it will ask, would
you like the mobile app?
And we hear from publishers
that their engagement on
mobile apps is orders of
magnitude higher than their
engagement on the mobile web.
And so we're trying to help
the publishers get more
distribution of their
mobile apps for
more engagement, right.
So they can have a really great
feature for users like,
hey, involve your friends, get
them to comment, get them to
watch, get them to read.
That simultaneously drives them
more app distribution
that simultaneously gets them
more traffic back from
people's friends on Google.
The last one, which I think
Sandy probably wants to talk
about, is what we just launched
around mobile content
recommendations, which
is great for
publishers on mobile web.
SANDY JEN: Right.
There's that where you create
a much more engaging
experience, where you try to
have the user come back to the
content of the publisher to say,
oh, look, I didn't know.
Let me pull this little
breadcrumb trail and fine
what's actually more interesting
on your site.
Then another point from what
Seth was saying before is we
actually had this concept at
Meebo where publishers these
days don't really understand
the individual
human face to a user.
Your IP address, your gender,
your age, your location.
How do you connect that
real life aspect?
And so with Google, what you can
do is that once you create
these communities, you actually
have faces to your
most addictive fans.
Like, a New York Times or a
small newspaper, may not know
this person visits theirs
site every day.
And they're spreading content
all over the place.
How do I create that connection
so that I, as the
publisher, am taking advantage
of that user, and creating a
circle around them so
they can start my
content around the web?
So that kind of evangelism is
really hard to do when you
don't have those tool sets, and
we're hoping that a lot of
our publisher offerings,
recommendations, circles, plus
pages, will then help create
that ecosystem to make it a
lot more engaging.
SETH STERNBERG: Actually,
riffing off that--
so Sandy just pointed out that
publishers often don't really
know who the person is behind
the IP address.
Something that Hugo announced
in his talk on Android
yesterday is what we're calling
cross-device single sign-on.
And this is huge, huge,
for publishers.
So if a user does connect on
web or on mobile, they can
start on either side.
The publisher finds out
who that person is.
They get their name.
They get their profile picture,
their public profile
data, and their list
of friends.
Now, there's a problem that we
have in our industry today,
that is we have this device
proliferation thing going on.
And so you might actually have a
user that's logged in on the
mobile device, but you have no
idea who they are when they go
to the web.
And that's a problem for
delivering them a more
relevant experience, because
you don't know who
they are in one place.
You do on another.
And it's a monetization problem,
right, because you
can't help figure out what this
person's interested in
from a monetization perspective
cross-device.
With single sign-on, if the user
connects on one device,
they are now connected on every
device because they've
created a relationship between
them and your service, not
them, your service,
and a device.
So that's another very powerful
tool that Hugo just
announced yesterday that
publishers can take advantage
of to create a much
more relevant
experience for their users.
The last one I'll just mention
really quickly, because,
sorry, you've asked a--
We've built a lot here, hoping
that we can really help both
developers and publishers.
We've heard from publishers
that in mobile web, their
bounce rate was unbelievably
high.
They have tons of traffic coming
in from social streams,
but people stay for 10 seconds,
they read an article,
then they vanish, right.
And I'll bet if you all think
about your use of mobile web
and social streams.
You're going through, you see
an article, you click, you
read for 10 seconds,
you're gone, right.
And what we've done on Monday
was we announced mobile
content recommendations.
We had partners come
in from Turkey.
They heard about mobile content
recommendations before
they got on the airplane.
They landed in SFO and they
had a little bit of time
before the car was coming
to pick them up and they
implemented mobile content
recommendations, literally
while they were sitting
in SFO.
It is that easy to do.
And that is designed to engage
a user in your site, in your
property, when they come visit
you, and drive you, then, more
page views.
DAVID GLAZER: I think--
I can't quite see the timer,
but I think we're down to
around five minutes.
OK.
So I want to get to as many
of you as we can.
We'll try to do some short
answers in the interest of
breadth, but--
back microphone, please.
AUDIENCE: My name
is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm coming from mobile.
I'm a communications
consultant.
One or two years I've had the
Stay Tuned list on features at
the platform.
It's about the API, it's about
Analytics, and it's about the
advantage URL.
And I'm just wondering, the
development that you how with
design and functions and
different functions like that,
which I love, is that a
conclusion that you won't make
regular read-write API?
That's the first question.
The second question is when will
we see a Google Analytics
for Google+?
Not for the Sign-IN functions,
not for the interactions with
websites, but for the engagement
on the destination,
the social destination as-is.
And the third question is
a regular guy question.
When are you guys going to
give people vanity URL?
SETH STERNBERG: Sorry,
what was the last--
DAVID GLAZER: Vanity URl.
SETH STERNBERG: Vanity URL.
So I'm going to take that
one really fast.
We have nothing to announce
on personal,
vanity URLs right now.
For read-write API, like
David said, we are
getting closer, right.
What we've done with Google+
Sign-In is getting a lot
closer to publishers
being able to
write stuff into Google.
We'll obviously keep pushing
the envelope, but we do not
have a read-write API that's
a straight write to
stream right now.
Like David said, it's because
we want to keep content
quality really high.
We will keep working on it.
The last question--
DAVID GLAZER: Analytics.
Google.
SETH STERNBERG: Analytics.
So definitely a request that
we've heard loud and clear
from the market.
There is some early social
analytics, both in Google
Analytics and as part of the
Google+ Sign-In release that
you can get from
your Plus page.
But request noted.
Next question.
[INAUDIBLE]
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah,
front microphone.
SETH STERNBERG: Just trying to
go quickly, and get as many--
AUDIENCE: Try and make
it as fast as I can,
for the sake of time.
One-word question, XMPP.
And then--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And then second
question is regarding
extending the schema for
individual users for
applications where you
use Google+ Sign-In.
Are you looking at being able to
say, use Knowledge Graph to
allow people to add schema to
people's identity for their
applications.
CHEE CHEW: So XMPP has two
modes, server-to-server and
client-to-server.
Which one are you particularly
interested in?
AUDIENCE: Client-to-server.
CHEE CHEW: So for
client-to-server, this is to
allow an additional apps
to connect in,
like a Pidgin or Adium.
What we found is that the
client protocol has been
pretty limiting in terms of
what we want to do and the
model for Hangouts.
So we have interop through
to the talk XMPP network.
And those apps will
continue to work.
But the protocol isn't as rich
to we do all what we want.
That'll be limited to one-to-one
text messages.
So you can continue to do that,
and we'll continue to
evaluate from there.
AUDIENCE: As far as integration
with users from
other presence environments
like Jabber,
and things like that.
Are you still going to be
able to do that, or no?
CHEE CHEW: So that's a
server-to-server federation.
And we have not seen a
really strong uptake.
There have been a few folks.
Actually, one of the biggest,
most frequent users of clients
of that server-to-server are
actually abusers and spammers,
who throw up a bogus network
and then try
and attack our users.
So far the uptake has not been
compelling for us to really
push that forward.
We'll continue to evaluate it,
but at this point, we've seen
more attacks on users than
benefit in reality.
DAVID GLAZER: And on the schema
question, catch me
afterwards.
I need to drill deeper and
we don't have time.
OK.
We have one minute left.
We're not going to get
to all of you, but
we're not running away.
So we will just walk out into
the hallway right outside that
back door for other questions.
Yeah, we have less
than a minute.
So thank you, everyone, for
coming, really appreciate the
questions and suggestions.
I've got a list of things
that we'll be
bringing back to the team.
SETH STERNBERG: Also, if you're
interested, we have a
full day of sessions.
If you're interested in learning
about Android, and
Google+ Sign-In, or
iOS, or whatever.
All of the sessions are today.
There's a partner panel later
today in which you can witness
what it takes to make a really
compelling integration.
There's a few other talks
that I can't remember.
Oh, Cross-Auth which
is the talk that
was mentioned yesterday.
And then Best Practice.
How to do best practices
on the platform.
DAVID GLAZER: Thank
you, everyone.
SETH STERNBERG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]